okay well let's get started so for
people who are joining us on the live
stream this is another episode in our
effort to design chemistry functionality
for from language and previously we had
mostly been talking about how to input a
molecule and I think we're largely
finished with that at least that's the
theory right
yes okay so where do we want to start
looking today see we want to look at the
options for this right so that's yeah
right so one thing that was different
that we from what we discussed before we
have atom positions and structure
diagram coordinates you can have 3d or
2d coordinates and so here you can put
automatic you can give specific or you
can give a method give method options to
to generating the coordinates hmm okay I
don't think it should be method options
I think it should be just maybe that's a
string or a function that specifies how
you should do it I don't think we want
to um I mean what what is the right-hand
side of the method option great so so it
would be a list of rules I believe is
what I've seen in a like graph layout
has things like that that's just a
method option I mean as opposed to this
specifically what are you saying this is
for automatic layout right rates but
then you could say for the automatic
layout I want it to be in canonical form
where you you put the long axis
horizontal to the to the x axis or you
make it resemble another structure
because that they're a bunch of detailed
options them yes as opposed to the pure
quantity array but even if you've got
the quantity array might you might you
not want to you know organize it like
which way the axis goes and where you
want the um I mean if you don't you want
to be able to specify you know lots of
things like even where the baseline is
if you have multiple molecules in a list
and so on you might want to say where
the how you want to line them up
vertically things like that
right I mean that's a question of how
the display it's a question of how the
display works right it's not so much the
coordinates as how it's embedded in the
outside okay so there are a bunch of
different issues there yeah there's a
bunch of things about baseline alignment
and so on which are what you would see I
don't know if graph has those things
certainly grid would have those things
you know what I'm talking about
I'm rates have those I mean we split the
coordinate we have the layout and then
we have all the traffic options okay so
show me that Charles oh gosh it is
broken on wait a minute is this is this
a new version hold on okay okay so those
are all those things and then where is
so they're just of this so we say we
support all the graphic options with the
following additional changes I see so so
this could do the same thing right I
mean I I whoo yeah I guess but go ahead
so with graph you can supply so it
splits those into two to two separate
ones you can supply vertex coordinates
but then you could also give a graph
layout where you can you can give a
named layout algorithm or and with those
named layout or algorithms you can then
give sub options although I don't know
that those are documented okay so we've
got vertex coordinates and then we've
got graph layout so we might want to
have a structure diagram layout that's
analogous to the graph layout thing and
that gives all of those details and then
we could say I mean we could do that
structure diagram layout and structure
diagram coordinates as two separate
options that make sense yes
um okay
stereo elements that has a nasty sort of
potential kind of to general a name for
what it is can we can we
stereo chemistry elements or something
stereo chemical elements just to give
some idea if somebody sees that just out
in the wild what the heck it is I mean
you could just say stereo chemistry
comes to I don't know how Bob would feel
about that yeah stereochemistry is
Finers to your chemistry elements I
would be a mystery element
stereochemistry is sort of a field I
mean it's I don't use it as a slang to
mean the stereochemistry of a of a
molecule but I think that's some okay so
stereochemistry element seems like the
right okay okay so this is now the
stereochemistry specification here yeah
and these are just some examples that we
had put together the the first one was
for a stereocenter we in the last
notebook not all the fields were filled
in so here's a concrete example with all
of the the fields filled in fiducial
atom the ligands and the direction
indicating whether or not it's going to
essentially be clockwise or
counterclockwise so hold on things so
this is just saying I'm confused here
okay so there are two real examples here
the Tri halo methane and the
stick-figure for the last one is
numbering the atoms so that we can
specify the just to fake yeah that's
just the fake this is what it should be
is that what is it this is what it would
the specification would be in the
molecule object with these atoms
numbered in this way so the
stereocenters the central atom which is
number one two fiducial atom which is
our reference
they - you know it indicating the
direction that we're looking toward the
central the stereocenter Adam okay the
ligands are Adams three four and five
and the direction for the handedness in
this case is counterclockwise oh yeah
but so what we discussed before is this
is great four carbons that are for you
know how valence four but what happens
with things with valence five and so on
that's a work in progress I just got the
papers from our library and when we
begin looking at those to see how to
handle okay it's fine so probably what
will happen is direction will become
something more elaborate in that case
yes yes hey we have a comment from the
live stream about atom positions and why
we're not calling that atom coordinates
well so I was using atom coordinates for
last time you made the comment there
they're not really coordinates there are
the positions I do I didn't quite
understand the distinction well the
question is okay coordinates are in work
the structure diagram coordinates are in
what coordinate system just the
coordinates of the the graphics frame so
there's structure it's just a 2d there
are one or something well Charles for a
graph what is the coordinate system for
vertex coordinates so if this turned out
you know are three coordinate system so
we can give any arbitrary position in
the space what you support are three yes
okay but not for graph yes I mean what
does this mean I mean this in other
words in a graph if I start giving 3d
coordinates what's it gonna do pop out
into space or is it going to give an
error you will actually be over and do
it in 3d oh okay
oh but only if it's if it has the graph
3d head right or am I know that is we
doesn't exist that is just
okay so the way that this was done is
that graph 3d is to emphasize the 3d
nature and the fact that it works in
graph two we don't advertise now it's
the luxury okay so what about is the
planar graph does it is it the same type
of thing whities just specified the
layout right so planar graph is just
feeding into graph as well so graph is
the main workhorse function here yes
okay so what we're dealing with then is
there arbitrary kind of computational
coordinates for the vertex coordinates
there right yes um and then the 3d
coordinates have are attached to a union
system right but I mean the 3d
coordinates are relative to what are
they route through the center of mass so
they're relative to what whatever we
feel like so to speak right they are it
is arbitrary I mean we we put the center
of mass at zero at the origin okay but
but so but then also with arbitrary what
the orientation of the coordinate system
is correct yes but I mean we have a
canonicalization no I understand but if
we're going to so my question is but
then you might want to draw a molecule
with a particular orientation with
particular coordinates yep and I'm now
completely confused about whether these
are the relative I mean there are
effectively relative coordinates and
then there are absolute coordinates put
this molecule at this position on in 3d
space right although there isn't a so in
a sense I mean the notion of atom
coordinates would be put them at these
absolute at this ok here's my question
if we've got something where we're
combining two molecules do they how do
they draw themselves do they look at if
their coordinate systems
sort of
you know into interpose themselves
that's gonna be goofy I mean really it
the molecule okay help me out here what
would we do with graphs in this regard
if you give two graphs you can't throw
two graphs into the same pot can you how
if you do a graph Union for example what
happens to the graph coordinates so
currently we just set a coordinate and
we use automatic methods so that's
essentially the something we plan to
work on which is the you know
inheritance of property which is you
know quite complex in general and it
doesn't limit yourself to just
coordinates so if I say graph Union how
would I do this if I if I give multiple
graphs like of this multiple instances
of this how would I do that a
disconnected graph with three copies of
this yes so you yeah you put three copy
oh so you should have move the least
what that's not doing what I thought it
was doing that that's that's taking each
one with its named coordinates right
yeah the one you want is love did you
want union okay well fine that's okay
okay fine so that's just placing them
arbitrarily yes okay so what will be the
analogous thing for molecules right soon
so if you do a molecule plot and then
give a list of molecules by default I
was thinking to move them like just like
graph disjoint Union out move them by
the amount of their bounding box okay
but the graph disjoint Union makes a new
single graph object and molecule plot
from molecule plot 3d doesn't do that
and this is kind of related to what we
were talking about the end of the last
session about creating ensembles or
clusters yes I mean so show would just
blast him on right right try to change
things um that doesn't make about a
sense you may have a more specific
scenario here you know and so what and
you know what are useful behavior in
that case in in our case right so for
example do we have move a molecule like
move its center of mass so so the
geometric transformation would would
work with on molecule was what I was
thinking like in all of the all of the
geometric transformations I see to
rotate to whatever else right Roger does
that make sense to you yeah and what
about the when you talk about a rotate
you know the natural center is the
center of mass for the molecule is that
representable easily with rotate see
what I'm asking I mean in other words
definitely rotation transform but you
design rotates lets see those those
rotation is purely for geometrical
graphic object right you know
overloading them I mean I'm not sure
that's the right thing to do here
well geometric transform is more general
and you can write that basically to be
whatever your fixed point is that you
want to use you can specify that it's
rotation around an axis in this
direction with a given point on that
axis actually rotate does that too now
yeah okay so they inherited dose yes so
currently geometric transformation is
made for is typically used on graphics
objects but I don't see anything in the
documentation that says it should only
be used on on graphics objects so I was
thinking to overload it but if if it's
if that's not preferable we could have a
molecule transformation that takes the
same transformation functions that
geometric transformation takes yeah I
mean the word molecule transformation
sounds kind of funky because it's like
you know some would sound more general
about the molecule but I think having
something which takes look Roger I mean
don't you have this issue with I mean
with regions and things things like
rotate and so on just work is that
correct they are starting to just work
now okay
so and and with a region is there also
this issue about having I mean to me
that seems like both region and molecule
need to have this kind of default
rotation center that might be the center
of mass or something like this my past
experience with molecules the
coordinates are absolute and if you just
gave it you know a three by three
rotation matrix it would assume it's
being rotated around the origin
I I don't think so because then then
you're gonna write the documentation and
you're gonna say the default rotation
Center is here for this and then you
know like and Roger it's clearly going
to be useful if you've got a you know a
a rubber duck or something represented
as a region right being able to turn the
thing upside down relative to its center
of mass it's clearly going to be a
useful operation or a teapot whatever
you want to pick I mean in other words
there are plenty of applications for
which it would be useful to by default
rotate around the center of mass and
there should be an easy way to do that I
mean I think with rotation transform you
can specify rotation SantaCon you yes
yeah when did I think but it you should
be able to construct that transform
without a lot of difficulty but long
winded I mean you know no absolutely no
I just wanted to think some more about
what the causes are of all that but yes
we go to make that easy that's for sure
okay but so in this case the real
question is what you are specifying in
this molecule thing really what you want
to specify what you might want to
specify is gosh either the relative
positions relative to the center of mass
or you might want to specify the orient
the position of the center of mass and
the orientation of the molecules or you
might want to specify absolute atom
positions that came out of something
like a dynamics code or some such other
thing that might have been like a
dynamics
code running on a multi molecule cluster
did that make sense yes so so for
automatic coordinates I mean for
automatic coordinate generation that we
would we would put the center of mass at
the origin if you provide the the
coordinates then then then there
whatever you say they are yes okay and
still okay a relative of the center of
mass there's still the the overall
orientation in space you know which
terrestrials so the question here is
whether why we're calling it atom
positions rather than atom coordinates
I think that we've actually got two
different things so the atom coordinates
could be relative coordinates or they
could be absolute coordinates well I
mean they're just some set of
coordinates that you give and then the
issue is how do we inherit those when
you have a cluster that has multiple
molecules in it also so then when you do
that when you Union numbers when you do
Mao I don't know what the function will
be I was thinking molecule add but there
could be molecule Union I suppose I
don't but there would be a default
behavior there whereas in if they and
where they would be moved to where their
bounding boxes don't overlap but you
could override that behavior yes well
okay so there's one but you're gonna
have the exact same su for graph as
we've just discussed right do you put
when you combine graphs with graph
disjoint Union do you put them to you
reset mean in other words what you could
imagine is saying in graph two strong
Union having vertex coordinates arrow
inherited means use the original vertex
coordinates and vertex coordinates are
automatic means automatically set new
ones
Charles Roger what do you think of that
yeah that's correct that's actually the
design you are planning to implement for
rate of parties great well so that
should work here as well so then it will
be Adam coordinates arrow inherited
versus Adam coordinates are automatic
for the combiner function makes sense
yep yes and so so we'll change that to
Adam coordinates the option okay okay
thank you - I know the problem is people
on the live stream it's that I don't
know how to say their names because well
thank you to the person who suggested
this um okay so let's let's keep going
for double bonds what is this about
well double bonds have a stereochemistry
as well for a simple double bond which
is the the schematic on the left that's
2 butene that can be either sister trans
and the specification there Jason and I
have been batting around to different
ways of doing it the first one we you
know the stereotype is now double bond
instead of stereocenter we have to
specify the two atoms that make up the
bond and then the two ligands that are
attached that are either going to be
apart or together across that bond so
wait a minute is this what's usually
called sis missus trans exactly well why
don't we using those names well sister
trans are an old version the accepted
stereochemistry z' is e or z 4n Kagan in
suits Amin which in English are apart
and together I see so that's why we
fully accept sis and trans as
alternatives yes we we probably can in
most cases while we accept all of those
all three of those both Jonesy yes and
gannets Amin yes sis and trans no
because there are some nuances carried
over from the old literature that are
not specific enough and that's why they
were replaced by e and z sometime in the
60s or 70s right but so there's a
distinction here when people usually use
the terms a and z and they talk about
stereochemistry they're talking about
absolute stereochemistry yes and what
we're trying to provide is allowing them
to specify the local stereochemistry to
determine whether a molecule is e or Z
you might have yes absolutely and in a
local sense to do it officially you need
to find what the priorities are of the
the four attachments to the double bond
and that means doing the graph search
and all this stuff and assigning looking
at the atomic numbers all the way out
until you can disambiguate everything
this way here we're keeping it local we
look at the four things we're saying the
four things have this arrangement and
it's you know the absolute arrangement
of being either apart or together so we
don't have to trace out the graph to get
the cahn-ingold-prelog priorities and so
essentially what we're the way we're
having it is you specify the local
stereochemistry around a particular bond
or a center and then the absolute
stereochemistry which goes into the name
or what not is is a computed property
right okay okay and we have Jason I had
two alternatives here for specifying the
double bond we could do it the first way
which is more or less the preferred way
where you just specify the two atoms in
the bond and then the two attachments
the two ligands and then the direction
the second method here is kind of like
for stereocenters where we have a
reference ion to see why one should I
don't see why you should you should I
mean the stereocenter thing is gonna get
blown up anyway with the five five
element things that they're gonna be
other weird things that like I would
like try to make it always look the same
okay so we can stick with the first one
then and not have to try to I think so I
wouldn't try and pretend as a phantom
okay that's fine that's fine I was just
trying to think you know what's
consistent from case to case versus well
but I predict that there'll be other
funky cases of stereochemistry that
aren't you know that don't necessarily
have a fiducial atom as you say yes yes
I mean it's a clump of local properties
of a graph that might not have a a king
atom so to speak in the whole thing yep
so people were the first one for double
bonds and then everything else is for
our stereochemistry goes is still on the
drawing board but for the first version
what we have right now for a
stereocenter in double bonds will be
sufficient fair enough okay so adjacency
matrix of this okay molecule what is
this doing
so this is just an example to show that
right now I have everything hooked up as
string value matrix real numbers what's
the one point five so so therefore in an
adjacency matrix for a molecule you
might want to have the bond order be the
the elements so or I can imagine they
might do that with edge weight so that
would be one and a half bonds an
aromatic bond one would be a single bond
to my default this should be this should
be exact numbers I was trying to emulate
graph I might be incorrect about that no
I do appears that I am incorrect about
that
okay code imagine the graph has an
adjacency matrix that's real numbers
does it yeah no I was wrong okay all
right so in terms of these bonds I mean
I don't know what's gonna happen with
packed arrays and things in terms of
well you're representing it as a sparse
array anyway so that's going to be
somewhat okay um in terms of those I
didn't I mean these aromatic bonds that
have half-integer valence so to speak or
half integer I don't know what you call
it one word order you know we just have
to localize the bonds Jason to do this
no I mean they could be three hands and
then would be fine I don't see why okay
one and a half is a perfectly reasonable
exact number so is that like a weight
not really Roger I mean it's it's when
you draw the diagram right it's whether
it's a double bond or not and I don't
know how you represent these aromatic
bonds they do that some people draw the
ring with a circle in the middle some
people draw them with the dry hexagon
and then they instead of having a solid
second line yeah they would have a
dashed line for all of the bonds so that
yes all is more consistent to me than
putting the circle in the middle right
that's the way your molecule plot right
now yeah the circle is falling out of
fashion well especially given that one's
going to say that they have you know
then it's kind of nice it's a it's a
multi edge that is a one and a half edge
so to speak which is something that I'm
sure Roger and Charles have not
considered for graph for the Gulf right
no but we have we have something that's
more general than that which is weighted
adjacency matrix okay so those weights
can be you know whatever you want them
to be right yeah that's great oh hi you
know not multiples 1/2 but PI whatever
you want no I understand and so so when
when we ask for adjacency matrix here
it's going through somewhat bizarrely
because we live in a quantum mechanical
world and all that kind of thing give
you half integer adjacency stuff out
representing these things like aromatic
bonds that are sort of a if I understand
correctly are sort of a feature of
quantum mechanics is that a fair
statement yes yes I mean it's hard to
imagine how they would work but a lot of
things you know weights you know
including multi graphs and so on you
know weighted graphs is the more general
concept no I understand I understand
okay let's keep going here okay
properties from molecules so multiple
properties can be queried returning an
association which probably will spell
check if I um we've got some background
noise somebody might want to mute
themselves
smiles in the entry for that particular
molecule fine is that the default thing
that we do is to return an association
when we have a list like this there
let's see so I think an entity value it
would just return a list then you have
to add it okay
then that's what we should do then so
the entity value then has a third
argument that is property associations
will emulate density value I think so I
would think so now what are these so so
then these these properties can have
attributes you can ask for the canonical
smiles you could ask for you could even
ask for the smiles just start at a
particular with additive value does that
the there are entity attributes right I
mean there are property attributes right
those given so I'm Michael might correct
me on this I believe if you just would
be entity that I was addressing to trace
we should have a molecule property where
we can have an outer head that would
allow to specify all kind of details
without this but if you're doing just a
single property hold Michael am i right
am I so me yes yes so if you're asking
for a single property though and it has
attributes do you need the entity
property head or can can it be just like
this it can be friendly but it would be
nice as a syntactic construct
I mean so molecule then becomes a thing
like an entity I mean we've discussed
this anyway in Katie yes right go ahead
what are you gonna say I mean what other
feature does molecule property with a
molecule property wrapper have other
than just keeping these options if the
another advantage that we wouldn't be
bad
- molecule of poverty but we could
similar to entity we could property of
molecule which in some cases might rust
read nicer okay right and you could map
a molecule property and over a list of
molecules right that's interesting okay
fine I think that's a direction we
should go but now what about the what
about what we're doing searches in the
same way that we're doing with entity
how does that you know how does that
relate so this is like um like implicit
entity classes right
I had not yeah not fully considered that
I mean there might be something
different here because at least
conceptually in the entity world there's
a fixed number of entities we go through
and it's much more scientists are like
operations yeah I agree they are not
fixed all right it's not completely
obvious to me but I would say
provisionally a molecule property thing
which can be a wrapper that holds these
things would be a good thing to do but
then for two beam to be nice as Michael
said if you just get one property in an
option that's yep but conceptually those
things are part of the molecule property
thing and therefore they don't have to
be documented options of their own and
things like this okay I don't know what
use bond order is supposed to do it
should I be looking at that I mean is
there a whole so so is so there if you
asked it would be the difference between
the way to do Jason see matrix in the
adjacency matrix if you don't use the
bond order then it would be all ones and
zeros for the adjacency matrix oh I
misunderstood the word order and was
thinking it was you know ordering as in
permutation okay well that's kind of
picky I mean it would be nice then to
say and by the way I don't see why you
shouldn't have the actual function I
think you had that up above using actual
adjacency matrix the function on a
molecule why not give the thing also I
didn't know if
if we want to overload some of the graph
functions for I would think so I don't
see a problem in doing that I mean
there's hardly any confusion there and
it seems like a nice thing to do but it
seems to me that we've got to be
consistent with adjacency matrix and
weighted adjacency matrix and that we
shouldn't that adjacency matrix should
be the zero one matrix because for many
graph operations that's exactly what
you're gonna want and by the way I
assume that graph of molecule will give
the graph of the molecule would you want
that to be just simple vertices and
edges or would you want it to have
essentially weighted edges and and
colored vertices in other words the atom
plays yeah yeah I would say yes so I
think you want I think you want
something that you could manipulate with
graph operations yes there are a lot of
applications for that so we should make
that easy but then on the way back you
should be able to say molecule of graph
and in fact what I would do is to say
molecule if just if I just do it for a
plain-jane graph like this okay I mean
it's going to probably complain that
that's not well is is there a way of
making that into a hydrocarbon that one
yes yeah if you assume strained right
but I think that would be a really nice
thing to be able to do to be able to say
given a graph you can just say molecule
of that graph and it turns into by
default a you know a hydrocarbon version
if you specify let's see I mean I can
imagine you specifying the atoms here
and then specifying a graph here for the
bonds making sense okay yeah you could
see so we want it to go both ways so we
want it to be the case that graph of a
molecule gives you a graph
and then manipulates and then if you
want to get that back into a molecule
again at the end it should be as
faithful as it can be I think right so
so molecule of a graph will look for the
properties so will will need to come up
when we make a graph out of a molecule
we need to come up with names for the
properties the way we give the atom type
and everything I think though and so
then so first we would look for those
properties and if they weren't there
then we would do as you say and assume
an all carbon I think so the other thing
is that it could you know that's
perfectly good okay but if you need to
provide additional control over how that
mapping is done and like you know maybe
you don't see that now but you might see
it later that it's important that
different but also very important
different ways of doing it because they
preserve different kinds of properties
of constructing the graph from the
molecule exactly right and so that I
mean so there I would think that you
would want to the so right now I would
have it as a graph as a string and as a
property of the molecule and it would
have option
it could have options as opposed but but
if you need to provide control for that
it it and and it's important then it
needs to be it should really be a
separate function because then you can
talk about why do you want to do it this
way or that way you can show why you
know you can that's the proper way to
describe it if it needs control if it
doesn't then right so like a new graph
constructor molecule graph for instance
yes but but that's only if you need to
Cano if there's a added value to do it
right you know okay okay so and then
finally weird not finally but now this
is a an important part that I I'm not
certain about the syntax for you want to
be able to query for properties both
given or computed of parts of the the
molecule I like the
syntax of property value with Granth but
I've been told well so but it wasn't
sure whether whether we wanted to go in
that direction so here you would have
molecule formal charges Adams goes to
five and seven to give you the charges
of the seventh and fifth atoms as
opposed to using property value you do
property value lists molecule comma and
then list of vertices list of edges and
then and then the name of the property
well that's just totally obscure but but
okay by the way a comment from a live
stream encouraging us to implement
adjacency matrix properly for molecules
and not just have it be an up value for
molecule fundamental problem in the
Wolfram language is that where where you
don't want to encourage a lot of things
like that because if you look at the
reference page for that it will be like
five different reference pages in one
for this thing it will do that for that
thing you will do this yeah I mean this
okay so the documentation is not object
or it's not sort of fermented nutrition
I'm saying it's I mean we have separate
pages for some like for the properties
we you know for entity types we are
having separate pages so we can't do
that if there are enough of them but you
know I'm still trying to understand what
this means so this is saying I mean the
fact that this formal charges thing like
for example adjacency matrix is its own
great big official grown-up function
thank you yes and it's not obvious to me
that these things I don't know how many
of these things there are but it's not
obvious to me that this shouldn't be a
grown up function as well that you know
if you say I mean is it obvious that we
shouldn't have a formal charges at
molecule and then all the specifications
and
so on so that it's a proper you know
first-class thing I mean why why are we
hiding it that's just some sort of weird
access or property of the molecule how
many of these things are that how many
of these sort of properties of a
molecule are there some properties of
the modular properties of the of the
atom well you've got okay so fair enough
look look so so maybe what you're saying
here is that you know what you're saying
is it's something like atom properties
in a molecule four atoms five and seven
this is the property I want
in other words extract those it's like a
part extractor for molecules five and
seven see what I'm saying so for example
that the most ned would definitely give
much cleaner code when you use it right
what about something like molecule part
five comma seven and then there's a
third argument and then by default that
just gives you whatever those our our
the atom representations for those
things and if you want to get atomic
numbers directly you could say I mean
I'm not sure that that molecule part is
necessarily the right name that might be
let's see molecule component molecule
elements or something that's that's
rather a silly pun and probably not
right yes but there's another
complication here Stephen and if you
specify you know a handful of atoms do
you also include the bonds among those
exactly what I was thinking cuz it's you
know the subgraph would do that for
instance yeah well so then we probably
want that we want atom properties and we
want you know sub molecule or something
sub structure okay should be like I know
like a subgraph and then there are bound
properties
okay well I think you know look the
world is made of atoms and things so I
think we can you know we can justify
having a function that represents
something about atoms so we'll have to
add is that we want them to be you know
L values so you want to be able to set
them so you end up with four functions
we can say atom properties if we if we
have this be like part we can make it be
set of all like part so but nomenclature
wise though atom properties does it
return the property value well I think
if you say if you have a third argument
there I'm not not necessarily selling
that name
okay I'm saying that that yeah so I mean
that would be with a third argument
without the third argument you'd want to
specify I mean this is well you've got
to be able to have a third argument
there but without the third argument
that should just return the actual atom
symbolic atom objects am I making sense
you are and and what's included in those
symbolic objects okay so the atomic
symbol or is that everything we know
about those atoms right so exude so it
certainly wouldn't be him I mean it
could be in a what do you the atom head
around an association like that would go
into the first part of the molecule
that's what it is
but but there's an implication here that
certain properties of the atom you there
they don't exist on their own so
neighbors might be a property of an atom
but it if you just get an an l-value
representing that atom it has no
neighbors or it has no okay the question
of what of how much you know how many
hanging loose wires there are in the
atoms that come out is a is one question
but the second question is in this case
where you just say mole here I mean I
think this is the right way to go is to
have actual official functions for this
I think we shouldn't try to do this we
should try to do an atom part
something like an important molecule
part or some that doesn't that's not
right those are not the right names but
the concept would be that this is a an
actual subgraph of the molecule right
whereas at impart is the list of atoms
that makes sense and that both of them
are L valuable so to speak so if you
want to substitute a single atom you
would basically say atom part of mole
comma 5 equals blah equals and then a
specification for an atom like a carbon
or you know or an entity right yeah just
as we would in input form yeah I think
this is a reasonable way to do it and
then you can also do you know a subgraph
l value here as well with molecule part
let's let's take a look here when you've
got molecule add for example okay so
that is the thing where you are it's
like an append to for a molecule pretty
much right how do you do that in the
case of you have a vertex ad in the case
of a graph correct yes okay so I'd
originally proposed to atom ad bond ad
but the idea is that these can be
combined with molecule ad and that and
if you provide a key then you can add
bonds and you know what you're adding
because if you add an atom object if the
second argument of molecule ad is an
atom object you know you're adding an
atom right okay and that could also be
overloaded to combine I mean to combine
molecules you could do molecule atom all
and then another molecule well I if it's
an not a molecule that has some hanging
valence thingy how do you add it other
than as a cluster
did that make sense right no I mean they
would be disconnected unless you
simultaneous and add a bond or add a
bond at the same time it provided that
you
but isn't that so when you add a bond
aren't you overwriting and I see if you
add a bond and it is at position right
you you can add a bond when you say
molecule add gosh I'm now confused you
does that also have the potential to
overwrite if you say atom five in
molecule add if you say atom and then
the atoms name is five then that will go
and overwrite atom five is that correct
how do you do that in a graph
how do you do that for the if you I want
to go to vertex five and a graph and
overwrite it and replace vertex v by
some sub Gulf how do I do that we don't
replace sub graphs replace a vertex with
a soup with a graph we have that extra
place for dance okay as opposed to so
but molecule add I don't even understand
how you would do that for a molecule if
you've got a complete molecule you can't
add an atom to it some kind of a own
thingy well traditionally in molecular
modeling with what this operation would
be would be to replace an existing
hydrogen for example on an atom by
something else so if you said atom it
you know atom edie molecule comma 5
comma chlorine it's gonna replace one of
the hydrogens on atom 5 by a chlorine
atom okay so I think that's a molecule
replace because it is a replacement
operation it's not yes yes I'm not
saying we need to use atom add for it
but you know from prior modeling systems
that's what chemists came up with for
their nomenclature of functions I
understand but I think we probably
should use replace because it's
replacing an atom at a particular
position with something
yes yes but in some cases that you're
only replacing a and implicit atoms the
hydrogens are second-class citizens and
sometimes they're not even given actual
numbers it's the easiest way yes yeah
there's that there's that issue as well
whether or not we've got hydrogen's
actually instantiated but aren't they
always there isn't that just to display
property or I thought it was no well no
I mean so they are sometimes always
sometimes there but sometimes you want
the molecule replace to somehow either
we have to have a separate molecule add
from the molecule replace or we have to
um I mean the molecule replaced doesn't
want to delete an atom or I guess I
guess it would in this idea that you're
deleting a carbon and replacing it with
with hydrogen's like with for functions
like these we would ideally want to just
treat them the hydrogen's automatically
yes I understand except when you want to
replace a hydrogen you've got to be able
to name that hydrogen right how do you
say what you're replacing unless you're
yeah so I don't think of it as a
replacement I think of that so you've
got ethane and you add a carbon to it
sure you you are technically removing a
hydrogen but I a lot of times you don't
even think about the hydrogen's you're
you add a carbon and you make a propane
it's the reason to wasn't that you know
when you don't show hydrogen isn't that
just a sort of an elysian technique you
know it's like it's easier to handle
visually there's the visual aspect of it
Roger I don't think we we came up with a
decision last time about whether or not
hydrogen's are always present they're
instantiated or not
and I think we need to nail that down
Jason
a lot of things they're not always
instantiated there they are sometimes
implicit but like lazy coordinates like
if you say molecule and then a list of
three carbons and a list of two bonds I
will assume that there are that each of
those carbons has a certain number of
implicit hydrogen's but they're not in
the actual list of atoms um guys
unfortunately we have run out of time
which is really a shame because there's
a lot of fascinating stuff here yeah we
yeah we do need to do that I mean at
some level we'll need to probably
schedule some some bigger blocks of time
here because we're making good progress
I think there's a fair amount to do I
just want to point out this highlights
thing doesn't isn't there a highlighted
rapper that is that we're using for
graphs and for images and things like
that that there is a function that
there's a thing called highlight graph
and there's a thing called highlight
image but I think that when I was
looking at this is I think that it
should be there is no other second
argument from all the cube plot is there
no no so isn't that one of the key
features of doing molecule plot to
provide highlight so it's an optional
second argument okay yeah because I'm
guessing that this is gonna be you know
often is you may not use it you know
just plot it okay but the second most
useful feature I think is probably gonna
be highlighting and I'm guessing I'm
just and Roger to add to that labeling
it you know I might want to put numbers
next to some atoms or arrows and things
like that I want to hook into the
call-out functionality I think mm-hmm
how will we do that because Cola usually
is symbolically put into the structure
itself right and we want to do that
specifically you know if you want a
custom do that so to speak you know yeah
I want to do my plot that I want to
label it just there okay yes for my
article or my presentation you know this
is my it's just a big cheese or whatever
you want to call it yeah all right okay
then
then you you can use those wrappers
there you know you can use labeled or
call out wrappers but then you have to
build a layout code underneath it
actually does you still have to do work
you know but but in terms of taking the
user specification at a fairly high
level and being able to sort of just
specify exactly what you need that this
is sort of clear how you would do that
and particularly if you make it an
argument it makes all the sense in the
world
okay sadly we have to wrap up here um I
look forward to continuing soon um okay
I'll see you guys later
sorry okay bye